first up order a business we must get to
Richard and Sal who are wearing diapers
and I don't want them holding it in
they're trying to compete in the
heaviest diaper contest no you're trying
there Sal and Richard in your diapers
plastic over here both of you guys are
wearing diapers Richard always gets into
like a Halloween or she's dressed as a
baby with a baby bonnet and baby [ __ ]
they're like plastic pants they're
wearing yeah well yeah peen I don't want
peel know that that pad can hold very
much man we should tell everyone what
this is gonna be do you guys have not
peed in your diapers right now yeah but
we can't I'm ready to go you want me to
you're gonna go right now I could let me
do that looks like okay go ahead I mean
when it's happening trying give us a
play-by-play
it's a weird I haven't peed on a diaper
in a while well not blowing it already
ready to make the rate what is it does
it like it's hard to sort of get it
going it is why cause it feels weird it
does I mean you're used to holding your
wiener in your hand and when your hands
are empty it's weird yeah well why don't
you just hold thousand or hold it might
go now - I think I could beat you
let's see go ahead this is odd Howard
are you right now we lose round this is
why I got into radio feels good yes full
adult piece change let me see yes
grosser my face is red you am i
imagining a smell of well this is it's a
plasticky smell from what we're wearing
that's not plan get closer if you want
I'm done are you done yeah we sounded
you go yeah no not yet I think I can
sound why is your bones so big in your
diaper
I got huge pores
I can't are you forcing well if I play
with your nipples
I just need to relax
now let me explain that while you're
relaxed maybe if I talk and go ahead
with the explanation part of this you'll
be better off so we have the whole
studio dressed up as a nursery at the
end of the show Robin whoever has the
heaviest diaper wins and he gets to lay
on the baby table and have the loser
change him
I don't even ask me why that you're
going right now to get Richard face warm
[ __ ] gross leaking my balls are wet
oh are you done just about ah and you're
gonna keep on the same diaper for a
couple of times yeah and then what are
you gonna do like save the diapers and
keep changing and yes yeah we don't want
to get diaper rash I guess no well
that's why when the person who ever
changes a baby pad when you take it off
you should weigh it right away so that
the urine doesn't evaporate
I think we're weighing it at the old boy
got a lot coming Howard I'm filling up
yes still I can feel it in the crack of
my ass no [ __ ] yep you said you I got
you I got enough [ __ ] you know I ain't a
road a little bit yeah I'm stopping and
going I think my penis is humid with it
yeah
it's just gushing out and then this
warmth and then my balls got wet and
then it did a nice go again and then it
went up to the crack of my ass around my
taint area now it's just it I just feel
like I've scrambled eggs in Bahia a
diaper just warm this is wild you look
so happy Richard with a pulled dice I
love it yeah I can just be free today
right you can just pee whenever you want
oh there's a lot there's a lot going now
I'm going right now full stream did you
drink a lot of water no I just had a
couple coffees
oh really are you nervous no but there's
a lot coming our kids go in a bucket I'm
going again because you guys are like
living in your own filth are you going
now Richard yeah when did you become a
job what are you doing you opened up
your butt yeah just looking I wonder
what your diapers way already
uh we can wait first one's really heavy
you have to come over and look inside I
think he's missing some men can I go
over to Fred for him to look take a peek
inside her Fred I kind of see it from
here but yeah come over go over there
nothing
then maybe you should go visit battery
pack
what do you see Fred but there's some
serious urine in the battery packing and
back of his diaper I wonder whose
heaviest at this point I know you want
to uh anybody want to wait an initial I
think there should be a weigh-in
you guys want to take a bet I'm betting
on South I don't know Richard went twice
I'll go with Richard how much you want
to bet all right yeah I'll take Richard
for 20 how you gonna wait who's over
there
come on okay and we should keep track of
I'm here what are you gonna do is plan I
guess they'll just take their diaper off
and put it right in here so Richard will
drop his in first Jerry will give us the
weight and then I'll drop mine after
rich okay the plastic is what looks like
one of those ballpark francs you should
talk about what it's dick looks like
yeah yeah I'm looking at one you Gary
weighted point to point to get it click
Gary acts all high and mighty like he's
never pissed in a diaper must feel good
to take off that wet diaper what
happened you dick where is it oh they're
[Music]
installing all right go ahead come on
don't [ __ ] around just stick that thing
on the scale
oh my god what point six
he was feeling that wet all up around
his butt crash Sal we point six IO Robin
20 bucks you are doing a dance victory
talk dance he's doing a [ __ ] dance hey
listen that's south penis hitting his
stomach so far the score is point 2
versus point six sounds gonna burn
himself out or yeah well anyway we Robin
of course I'll give you your 20 you guys
could go for round two Howard will come
back in anybody feel like they have to
pee not know all right boys so give us
the update when you feel like you have
to pee let us know and you guys could
take bets again it sure all right
everybody loves the diaper challenge